the delta variant is a growing cause for
concern for those who aren't fully
vaccinated
victoria saha explains why some choose
to skip their second vaccine victoria
while johnson johnson vaccine is just
one shot and you're fully vaccinated you
need two doses of the medurana or pfizer
to be fully vaccinated
however some think they might have
enough protection against the virus
with just one dose but what good does it
do if people just stop at that first
vaccine the biggest complaint has been
side effects
for some mild for some rough and those
who felt ill from it have been concerned
about the second dose
side effects are normal valerie matlock
says her whole family is fully
vaccinated except her daughter
who reacted badly to that first dose
soccer
gap derma and it immediately took her
out she came home she was shaking
the first dose of the vaccine primes the
immune system
or gets it ready for the infection the
second dose or the booster
magnifies that immune response to really
provide
much more protection against a viral
infection
matlock says she's hoping the first dose
that her daughter got will protect her
if she's exposed to the delta variant
but health officials say you are fully
protected against the delta variant if
you are fully
vaccinated if you are behind on your
second vaccine health officials say you
can still get your second dose
there is not a cutoff mark live in the
newsroom victoria saha 8 news now